Previously, we learned the
concept of independent
experiments.
In this exercise, we'll see how
the seemingly simple idea
of independence can help us
understand the behavior of
quite complex systems.
In particular, we'll combined
the concept of independence
with the idea of divide and
conquer, where we break a
larger system into smaller
components, and then using
independent properties to
glue them back together.
Now, let's take a look
at the problem.
We are given a network of
connected components, and each
component can be good with
probability P or bad otherwise.
All components are independent
from each other.
We say the system is operational
if there exists a
path connecting point A here
to point B that go through
only the good components.
And we'd like to understand,
what is the probability that
system is operational?
Which we'll denote
by P of A to B.
Although the problem might seem
a little complicated at
the beginning, it turns
out only two
structures really matter.
So let's look at each of them.
In the first structure, which we
call the serial structure,
we have a collection of k
components, each one having
probability P being good,
connected one next to each
other in a serial line.
Now, in this structure, in order
for there to be a good
path from A to B, every
single one of the
components must be working.
So the probability of having
a good path from A to B is
simply P times P, so on and so,
repeated k times, which is
P raised to the k power.
Know that the reason we can
write the probability this
way, in terms of this product,
is because of the
independence property.
Now, the second useful
structure is parallel structure.
Here again, we have k components
one, two, through
k, but this time they're
connected in parallel to each
other, namely they start from
one point here and ends at
another point here,
and this holds for
every single component.
Now, for the parallel structure
to work, namely for
there to exist a good path from
A to B, it's easy to see
that as long as one of these
components works the whole
thing will work.
So the probability of A to B
is the probability that at
least one of these
components works.
Or in the other word, the
probability of the complement
of the event where all
components fail.
Now, if each component has
probability P to be good, then
the probability that all key
components fail is 1 minus P
raised to the kth power.
Again, having this expression
means that we have used the
property of independence, and
that is probability of having
a good parallel structure.
Now, there's one more
observation that will be
useful for us.
Just like how we define two
components to be independent,
we can also find two collections
of components to
be independent from
each other.
For example, in this diagram,
if we call the components
between points C and E as
collection two, and the
components between E and
B as collection three.
Now, if we assume that each
component in both
collections--
they're completely independent
from each other, then it's not
hard to see that collection
two and three behave
independently.
And this will be very helpful
in getting us the breakdown
from complex networks
to simpler elements.
Now, let's go back to the
original problem of
calculating the probability of
having a good path from point
big A to point big B
in this diagram.
Based on that argument of
independent collections, we
can first divide the whole
network into three
collections, as you see here,
from A to C, C to E and E to
B. Now, because they're
independent and in a serial
structure, as seen by the
definition of a serial
structure here, we see that the
probability of A to B can
be written as a probability of
A to C multiplied by C to E,
and finally, E to B.
Now, the probability of A to
C is simply P because the
collection contains
only one element.
And similarly, the probability
of E to B is not that hard
knowing the parallel
structure here.
We see that collection three
has two components in
parallel, so this probability
will be given by 1 minus 1
minus P squared.
And it remains to calculate just
the probability of having
a good path from point C to
point E. To get a value for P
C to E, we notice again, that
this area can be treated as
two components, C1 to E and C2
to E connected in parallel.
And using the parallel law we
get this probability is 1
minus 1 minus P C1 to E
multiplied by the 1 minus P C2
to E. Know that I'm using two
different characters, C1 and
C2, to denote the same node,
which is C. This is simply for
making it easier to analyze
two branches where they
actually do note
the same node.
Now P C1 to E is another serial
connection of these
three elements here with
another component.
So the first three elements are
connected in parallel, and
we know the probability of that
being successful is 1
minus P3, and the
last one is P.
And finally, P C2 to E. It's
just a single element
component with probability of
successful being P. At this
point, there is no longer any
unknown variables, and we have
indeed obtained exact values
for all the quantities that
we're interested in.
So starting from this equation,
we can plug in the
values for P C2 to E, P C1 to E
back here, and then further
plug in P C to E back here.
That will give us the final
solution, which is given by
the following somewhat
complicated formula.
So in summary, in this problem,
we learned how to use
the independence property among
different components to
break down the entire fairly
complex network into simple
modular components, and use the
law of serial and parallel
connections to put the
probabilities back together in
common with the overall success
probability of finding
a path from A to B.